foreign
I'm the deputy City Manager for public
health and safety I've been with the
city of El Paso for 31 years we're used
to these surges this one what we're
preparing for now you know title 42 did
expire last night it it's it's it's at
that low it does feel like that calm
before the storm we know that there was
over 17 almost 1800 apprehensions by
border patrol in the El Paso sector
yesterday alone we know that they're
they're CPC processing center is over a
capacity they're well over six thousand
in custody at this point in time and so
those numbers will see a throughput
there will be released and so we'll be
seeing those numbers coming throughout
the weekend but it's that surge coming
from across the border that we just
we're not seeing you know whether
whether they're waiting whether they're
trying to take the legal pathway that
the time will tell with them what we're
seeing now is is the shelters that are
that are full in a capacity those are
our normal homeless shelters so those
are the two main shelters that are
taking care of our homeless Community
right here in El Paso and so those are
the ones that are seeing that a little
Spike we have been preparing we've been
preparing for a long time we've got two
schools that we've converted into to
mass shelter operations and so we've
opened one of them last night but the
numbers are really low you house 150
150 and we're seeing what title 42 going
away they don't have that option to
return anymore
right now they put a stay last night on
the ruling where they couldn't do the
rapid paroles well rapid pearls it means
people are released a lot quicker than
normal and that's where it really
burdens the city so with that going away
I think that's why we see it today with
lesser numbers I think if that hadn't
had a stay on that last night we would
be seeing a large influx right now of
them decompressing their shelters
because like I said they're well over 6
000 at this point in time when they get
to that that capacity if they go to
those rapid paroles that's where we see
a lot of three throughput then we also
with title 42 going away and the
restrictions would would title eight I
mean there's some serious penalties for
those Crossing in illegally so we're
worried that they're going to
but they're going to continue that
password of trying to get into the
country and while it's illegal that
means they're not going to be showing up
at the shelters they're not going to be
and so we'll have them within the
streets and that's where we've had
issues over the past couple of weeks and
it's a population that's very difficult
to take care of because like I said we
cannot legally offer them assistance and
so that's what creates the difficulties
here in our community We Are All One
Nation we're one community and while we
are got vast land around us right here
the people are crossing through they
don't want to stay here they want to get
as far from the border as they can most
of them are choosing the East Coast
whether it's Jersey New York
Philadelphia it's just all along the
east coast and that's where they're
choosing to go so this population is
going to continue to move onward and
they will you know they might not be
seeing it today
more than likely in the next few days
they're going to start seeing their
population increase and these are where
places where people want them to call it
home and so as a nation we should all be
concerned it is important to keep track
of it there needs to be policy chicks at
the federal level they need to come
together and they need to make the
policy changes
while I understand people want to come
to America they want that shot they want
that piece of the American dream
they understand that but there has to be
an orderly process to it and to allow it
to happen in these border communities
makes it difficult for us and it's it's
hard to handle while we seem prepared
it's because we've lived through several
surges over the past few years
and we've seen what those surges can do
I mean it's it's the people living in
the street the ones who are coming in
here completely illegal who are just
camping out in our streets it's the
having to go through multiple times a
day and clean the streets just to make
sure it's sanitary and it's health and
we're not risking those those issues
coming in is not is not just a
free-for-all that it has to be a process
you have to register you have to set
your appointment
was hearing this morning that they're
setting court dates out until 2035. and
that's you know what kind of a fair shot
are they getting I understand they want
to come and they want to work but are
they going to be allowed to work in that
time and so I think that's the policies
they need to clarify so that they can be
self-sufficient and not rely on the
system and it's a concern it's concern
for the safety of of not only the
migrants themselves but the community at
large and so yeah I think the plus time
for those policy changes